Houston your movie sucks
come on give us there
Paolo 18 takes the whole Paranormal
Activity Cloverfield route and does the
found footage we found this footage it's
real you know it's in your faces it's
happening right now this is real footage
so be terrified I think of all the films
of those I have seen Cloverfield is my
favorite because that movie was like
aware of it you know it wasn't like
trying to make you actually think it was
real like the Blair Witch or whatever it
was like yes we know this is not real so
have fun with it this movie is not like
that like the man that maybe it's like
this is the phone footage of this that
has been the public shadows for many
years and watch this and die and it's
really stupid because I'll get the I'll
get to why it's dumb in a second some
astronauts are going to the moon it's
Apollo 18 and it's supposed to be the
footage that explains why we've never
went back to the moon and you know it's
like this big secret thing and all this
stuff that happened up there there's
some kind of thing on the moon that
causes problems in blah blah blah blah
sounds like it could be fun right well
you know what matter is what I was going
to say earlier you see the whole movie
they try to make you think that this is
real and this is that this is you know
this is serious
legit stuff right here and be scared and
then like as soon as it ends like 10
seconds go by this isn't a spoiler or
anything but like 10 seconds go by it's
like directed by written by produced by
I'm like you guys think we're dumb I
mean seriously it's so stupid how they
just like trying to throw it in your
face that it's some real thing and then
like immediately the credits start
rolling you see all the Hollywood names
it's so stupid there are a few times
when I jumped and it's all jump scares
it's all like some loud noise and that
you don't expect and this and that
there's a couple little moments that I
thought oh that's a little bit chilling
what's the film ends it's 100%
forgettable
I mean it's instantly forgettable
nothing sticks with you literally
nothing I mean I walked out this movie I
was just kind of like alrighty then on
with my day
we've been experiencing unexplained
malfunction look at this Flags gone
crack
they aren't ours the story of the film
like while you're at what's actually
going on and what's there and how it all
connects to various things it's very
muddled and uninteresting and it makes
no sense it was supposed to come out
like last year and now it's something
outs then it was later this year and
then it was this August and this spring
and it all over the place plus it has
not been screened for critics all very
bad signs so good things in this movie
the acting is not terrible or anything
it's it's convincing that there are
these two guys stuck in the ship and
they're starting to hate each other
there are some good scares there are
some good chilling moments the movie
didn't bore me that much I mean I was
semi interested in what was going on
there were some boring moments where I
was like okay let's let's let's get
going here but basically the movie is
just completely forgettable the scares
are minut and quick and not long-lasting
that the the feeling of suspense you're
supposed to have is not there
there are much better found-footage
drums out there which I got Cloverfield
I'm going to give Apollo 18 SC I don't
recommend seeing it please go see the
debt seriously go see the debt I want
people to see that movie check it out
but if you liked my review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuff
guys